Wife 500 What are you doing in a place like this
?
[Music]
You look like a fairy Emilia
, you can't say bad things about people like that, and even I get angry.
No, yeah, even if he's
a pick-up line that's hindered by his differences, a 3 Ria-tan stays up late and walks south at night, and if Puck is there, it's bad for your beauty.
So I was taking a walk in the night wind
After all, it's the anxiety of the
ordeal, isn't
it?
If you come in,
oh
[music]
Song I'm a pinch hitter no matter how far I go The
British media are admirable Actually, you
should be able to think you want to run away I can
face it without getting discouraged I respect you
suddenly  What's wrong, it's
not a cow I
've always been thinking about it, but I've finally been able to say it I
don't know how much my words can help but I'll put my feelings into words
Emilia will be fine I'm sure you'll do it
[music]  ]
I'm on your side
[music]
Thank you
at I got
so much
snow